there was that stuff with Theo vaugh he
was upset like so many of my jokes
I'm happy that you brought that up yeah
it was like a wooden shirt and then you
guys had in the show now I remember when
we came up with the wooden stuff in the
writer's room and ended up doing one
small really inconsequential scene of my
Series where a guy was just selling
wooden shirts I promise you it wasn't
I've never and I whenever I see content
of theovon online as I'm scrolling I
totally think it's funny and I respect
it I've got no animosity I've just never
met him we have so many mutual friends
now you have a million pieces of content
that are out there in the world and
you're going to see people with similar
ideas I don't think it like immediately
means that one person is stealing from
another right two people can have the
same idea it's a pretty broad idea the
idea of wooden clothing yeah I I don't
know like I'm sure I mean I just think
you guys are both great and I would love
you guys to both just be like hey set it
up you're friends with everybody I will
set that for you I will set that up
great